famous fire breathing praying mantis at  container park  it is coming back to life it is a  positive sign for downtown where  business is finally starting to pick up  again  first friday returns in person tomorrow  night in the arts district  the monthly party has been all virtual  since april of last year basically since  the shutdown started  some downtown business owners tell us  they're seeing pre-pandemic levels of  foot traffic  at local restaurants and shops yeah it  is so great i mean you know the fact  that you know the city has just  continued to support us you know even  through the pandemic  i mean they're still coming here and  they're still you know staying true to  us i mean it's it's really awesome to  see  some credit vaccinations and just pen up  energy for the boost people ready to get  out  city of las vegas has also put up some  banners and key districts near downtown  like restaurant row down carson avenue  to promote business